I think my husband is in that room guys
I do the bachelorette reveals her
frontrunners only et was on set to give
you a sneak peek at Jojo Fletcher's
first group date things get heated at a
firefighter training academy I think
firefighters were super hot any
individuals sticking out so far Jordan
Luke and I I kind of picked up on Robbie
today
Robbie was a little dark horse for me
the first night but after seeing him
today I have a good feeling about him or
what made the difference for today I
don't know I think honestly the first
night he was so nervous so nervous he
couldn't say anything and then today
he's just totally himself and it's great
yes Jordan Rogers that is in line with
what went down on the premiere I am
really excited about you and at the
Academy I also spoke to Luke I had a
good day so I'm a competitor and it was
it was a lot of fun so okay a good day
does that mean a good day with Jojo how
are the vibes today yeah we we did it
we've had a connection day so Jojo said
it herself her three frontrunners are
jordan luke and robbie but wearing heavy
gear fighting fire and trying to win
JoJo's heart it was a lot and some of
the other guys did not do so well it is
so hot out here and they are just dying
Wells did you pass out today or did you
almost it I almost did am I having a
hard time speaking with you you seem a
little tired a lot tired on a scale of
one to ten how sweaty are you right
really you want to hug you want to see
you